so we just pick any song that works yeah
and you just go with it
nice and our next category is John's
about sex
[Music]
sex baby let's talk about you and me
let's talk about all the
all the good sex all right all right
let's talk about sex baby
[Music]
that brings out the man in me
I know I can help myself
[Music]
[Applause]
Creations bump like acne no doubt I put
it down never flout as long as my
credits about your dog couldn't catch me
straight up tell me who can stop when
Dre making moves attracting hunting is
like a magnet giving them orgasms with a
mellow accent still moving the flavor
with the homies Blackstreet and Teddy
the original rump shakers
keep going
shorty get down good lord
baby got them open all over town
strictly busy don't play around cover
much ground got game by the pounds
each and every day to play away I can't
get out of my mind oh wow okay
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean you're welcome
seems like everybody's got a price I
wonder how they sleep at night when the
sale comes first and the truth comes
second just stop for a minute and Smile
everybody looks tonight
[Music]
money money
you come see about me
I'll be alone
dancing you know it baby
[Music]
[Applause]
will you call my name
as you walk on by
[Music]
will you call my name
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight baby
[Applause]
[Music]
excuse me
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
okay the car's moved nothing else
happened yet but they're moving
backwards
with ghosts driving them
sound machine a German Collective
operating in concert to create Sonic
Sonic Mastery what better way to
appreciate Automotive perfection
[Music]
boss baby
[Applause]
's all dumbled down and hope that we
will never see the truth
another foreign
stop please
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
pick up the pace girls come on today we
are going back to the basics to relearn
how to sing as a group while also
enduring death-defying team building
trust exercises what a great idea okay
so let's begin
[Music]
he was a famous trumpet man from Old
Chicago away
[Music]
[Applause]
and now it's time for a breakdown
[Music]
Never Gonna Get It Never Gonna Get It
Never Gonna wanna get it
Never Gonna Get it
okay that was two steps away from being
almost fine
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
cause I look around flashlight
[Music]
oh look at this it looks like the Barden
Bellas are being joined on stage by
generations of Bellas going all the way
back to the beginning
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
let's go ladies
[Music]
[Applause]
touch me right
is that feedback
yeah so you guys saw what we did there
right so
it's singing no well we just took the
last word of the old song and matched it
with the first word the new song but you
stay on Tempo stay on beat stay on pitch
and of course keep it in the relative
key that was great that was really well
done okay okay okay round two let's keep
it simple this time what about
artists you didn't know were Jewish
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
and if you're ready
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
huache
[Music]
heaven knows I was just a young boy
didn't know what I wanted to be
foreign
[Music]
whoa I think there's something you
should know I think it's time
[Music]
all we have to see is that I don't
belong to you and you don't belong to me
[Music]
[Applause]
free up free
stuff
[Music]
I'll let you down
gotta have some faith in the sound it's
the one good thing that I've got I won't
let you down
it's the one good thing that I've got
[Music]
[Applause]